hey what is up guys and cabbie HD here
and normally when you think of Android
tablets you don't think of Dell I needed
it uh but they're starting out 2015 on a
pretty hot note with their first entry
into the high-priced mid-sized Android
tablet category with this this is the
Dell Venue 8 7000 so obviously the
design is the number one thing that's
gonna stand out here first of all it's
the world's thinnest tablet actually
didn't know that when I got it it's six
millimeters thin although not exactly
sure that's a good thing being so thin
it has square edges and being thicker
wouldn't make it any more difficult to
hold or anything and it's actually kind
of hard to pick up off a flat table so I
wouldn't mind it being a little bit
thicker or a little bit more rounded to
house some extra battery but there you
have it it's super thin and when you
take a step back is probably going to
remind you of the sharp aquos crystal
that I reviewed not too long ago but
blown up into a tablet size so it has
the three thin bezels around the top and
sides and one big chin with a front
facing speaker and front facing camera
on the bottom and this is a pretty
polarizing design I think it's actually
really cool for a phone but it's a bit
different on a tablet phones these days
are mainly for use with one hand in
portrait mode but tablets like this are
more often used with two hands so it
gets switched to landscape a lot this
Dell tablet really seems like it's meant
to stay portrait and stay in one hand
because when you turn it sideways things
get weird you know as the speaker's
supposed to be on the left side or on
the right side there's no palm rejection
technology like iPad set so you got to
be careful about how you hold it on the
thinner side I don't know it seems like
the design is better suited towards
phones but you can make it work now this
speaker on the chin here it's a stereo
speaker actually and it gets pretty loud
which is difficult to muffle by accident
but there's no stereo audio image since
everything is coming from one side which
is a shame because it's actually a
really good speaker but you do have of
course this good chunk of metal over
here on the side to grip to hold it and
I gotta say it's overall a very
well-built tablet got handed to Dell
with the metal chassis and the tactile
very clicky buttons I liked I'm sure you
could bend it if you tried hard enough
but at least you don't sit on your
tablet so the one thing that actually
did annoy me
the build materials was this glass on
the back it does house the rear facing
cameras I'll talk about in a bit but
it's a serious fingerprint magnet which
is not pretty and also the first one of
these tablets that I had shipped to me
from Best Buy the packaging was a little
bit bumped in just a little bit on the
corner but because the tablets it's so
close to the edge of the packaging this
little bruise turned out to be a big
crack on the corner of the tablet the
weakest spot obviously this isn't going
to happen to everyone but I have to
mention it but my new one obviously has
no problems so these midsize tablets are
getting more and more beautiful and
powerful and this is in addition to both
of those trends so it's rocking an 8.4
inch 2560 by 1600 OLED display and it is
beautiful you can see with these dull
live wallpapers and all kinds of stuff
it is seriously one of the best-looking
tablet displays I've ever seen it's
sixteen by nine so it handles videos
well movies look fantastic and that's
really what these tablets are all about
right media consumption and also gaming
gaming looks really good again if you
can get past the weird grip ergonomics
and the one sided speaker this is about
as good as games can look on an Android
tablet super bright colorful vivid
saturated great viewing angles and
everything it's really nice and with all
these pixels gaming performance is also
very impressive but now I'm just you
know playing regular not super intense
games like Leo's fortune and Riptide gp2
and Real Racing 3 but it handles them
all really well and I guess you could
say portrait games are its specialty
with audio coming out from the front
facing speaker feels kind of like this
thing was built for breaking Temple Run
records anyway pass gaming all these
pixels tend to make near stock Android
elements look pretty small but also very
sharp and in everyday performance with
this 2k display
I did see dropped frames not really like
lag or slowness but definitely dropping
frames which made animations look like
they stutter even though they go the
correct speed it's roxeanne android 4.4
kitkat
hopefully lollipop very soon to improve
performance a bit and it's fairly
lightly customized so nothing too crazy
like a heavy skin but some stuff is
added for the Dell and Intel experience
but it stays pretty close to stock
Android in the look and feel so it's
rocking an Intel Atom quad-core
processor at 2.3 gigahertz and
two gigs of ram and has little additions
like max audio which stays permanently
in your notifications but it's really
just a shortcut to a super simple
equalizer and stuff like my dell in
quick settings and other things to flip
to silence and intel smart video they
all kind of sit buried in the settings
little things that I use maybe once or
twice to demo them but then never really
found myself using again so I just
really use it like any any other Android
tablet really and the rest of the
experience is pretty familiar so it's
great for that stock android kitkat
is compelling to use here in portrait
mode which is fine it's just weird
because it feels like a giant phone
experience instead of a small tablet
experience the tablet has three camera
sensors on the back that are pretty much
impossible to take a picture with
without blocking them somehow but
they're supposed to combine to take 8
megapixel photos and also record depth
information using intel's realsense
technology it might remind you of what
the HTC One m8 did with its duo camera
sorry Dale I didn't really use it
Alabama much it's a tablet and I don't
really use my tablet to take pictures
for any sort of exotic reasons other
than to just have one to scan barcodes
or something so it's there I only really
used it once because it required the
Dell gallery app to actually take
advantage of any of these features it
looked like it worked ok but yeah it
didn't really use it so at the end of
the day this is one of the more
head-turning interesting looking Android
tablets out there and it's a risk it's
not necessarily my favorite design I
still think there are better ways to do
a mid-size tablet but I'm glad Dell took
the risk and taking risks is good that
being said I don't think I would
recommend this as my first choice for a
tablet in this midsize category there
are still over things like the Nexus 9
the iPad Mini retina and even the Nvidia
shield tablet that I think are all
better buys for this approximate size
and price I would probably recommend
this more if it was 100 bucks less but
still good on Dell for taking the risk
and it's their first dip at getting
their feet wet in the premium Android
tablet category I would still give the
edge to this in the display department
over pretty much any other mid-size
tablet but it depends on how much you
weigh that against the other things so
there you go that's the Dell Venue 8
7000 thanks for watching this review and
if you enjoyed it feel free to hit that
thumbs up button below and also there's
a subscribe button below if you want to
see more videos like
this again thanks for watching and talk
to you guys in the next one peace